[Música]
Bienvenidos a un nuevo episodio de
boleto de vuelta que en esta ocasión nos
lleva a Francia donde hace 30 años
ocurrió la catástrofe del estadio de
furiani en la isla francesa de córcega
allí un día de fiesta para los fanáticos
del fútbol se convirtió en una pesadilla
el 5 de mayo de 1992 el Sporting Club
bastia recibía al Olympique de Marsella
en la semifinales de la copa de Francia
para la ocasión el estadio armonces de
furiani había duplicado su capacidad
pasando de 9000 a 18.000 asientos y en
tan solo una semana se había construido
una enorme Tribuna metálica para acoger
a los numerosos aficionados incluso
antes de que comenzara el partido
mientras el público empezaba a tomar
asiento los trabajadores seguían
apretando tornillos varios funcionarios
de seguridad se mostraron preocupados
por el estado de la tribuna que aún era
inestable y efectivamente Al comenzar la
transmisión televisiva La Tribuna
derrumbó los espectadores cayeron 15
metros esta catástrofe dejó 19 muertos y
más de 2.300 heridos los responsables
fueron condenados en 1995 tres años
después de la tragedia la pena máxima
era de dos años de cárcel pero la
mayoría de las sentencias fueron
reducidas en apelación tres décadas
después se han curado las heridas han
cambiado las normas de seguridad Esta es
la historia
[Música]
las heridas del pasado cicatrizan
cicatrizan lentamente y dejan marcas
fácil y el dolor que podría habernos
devorado terminó dándonos fuerzas
en el momento de la tragedia el número
de víctimas representaba el 1% de la
población de La Isla
cada familia Corsa tenía un pariente
amigo o conocido afectado por la
catástrofe
hace 30 años el sol se ocultaba y había
un buen ambiente
todos estábamos acostumbrados a ver a
nuestras familias a saludarlas Y
entonces vimos que la tribuna se cayó
pensábamos que era una ola pero no
veíamos que la multitud volviera a subir
poco a la derecha un poco a la izquierda
Ese fue el principio
ahí fue donde
hay derecho hacia abajo
[Música]
esa sensación de ser absorbido hacia el
suelo y luego nada un agujero negro
que tal vez perdí el conocimiento
durante dos segundos y el golpe abajo me
despertó
vimos personas perforadas había dos
personas yo estaba en medio de ellas que
desafortunadamente fallecieron
me sorprendió mucho el número de heridos
que ya había ahí había personas en todos
los corredores que estaban acostadas que
estaban heridas no sabíamos realmente
qué les pasaba Y el personal médico
estaba claramente desbordado
[Música]
entre las personas más gravemente
afectadas se encuentra Paul kalasi
hemorragia interna fractura de vértebras
a los 43 años su vida de un giro el
fisioterapeuta venía y me decía
doble la pierna derecha doble la pierna
izquierda para mí en mi cabeza estaba
doblando las piernas no estaba al tanto
de la paraplejia
y lo supe cuando llegué al centro de
rehabilitación Paul así tuvo que volver
a aprender a hacer las acciones
sencillas de la vida cotidiana en 1992
trabajaba en la restauración un oficio
que había elegido y que le gustaba una
profesión que desde entonces le es
imposible ejercer
[Música]
y habría encantado mantenerme ocupado no
físicamente pero ser capaz de estar ahí
para trabajar en primer lugar me habría
gustado porque me habría dado algo que
hacer
uno se levanta por la mañana sin ningún
propósito no hay nada que hacer y no es
como las vacaciones pagadas es todo el
año y es la Planet
a pesar de su paraplejia Paul solía
salir de su casa y tenía vida social
Pero en la última década su salud se ha
deteriorado como consecuencia de las
numerosas complicaciones derivadas de la
tragedia su pierna derecha tuvo que ser
amputada lo que redujo aún más su
movilidad
no es fácil desplazarme
uno no se mueve no hace ningún esfuerzo
no se cansa
oceles se deja llevar y ya
al igual que polcal así las vidas y los
cuerpos de las otras víctimas de furiani
también quedaron destrozados además de
las heridas físicas algunos quedaron con
heridas invisibles pero igual de
devastadoras
vivir gracia era periodista En aquel
momento estaba sentado con sus colegas
en la zona de prensa de La Tribuna norte
sobrevivió de milagro gravemente herido
sufrió durante mucho tiempo de estrés
postraumático un término desconocido
hace 30 años su encuentro con el
psiquiatra Richard redman le permitió
poner palabras a estas cicatrices
psicológicas iba a verte al final de la
conferencia para que me dieras algunas
explicaciones sobre ese famoso
Cómo se llama el trauma del
sobreviviente el síndrome del
sobreviviente
me hablaste la dificultad que tenías con
eso y luego de la dificultad que tenían
los demás para hablar de eso
me recordó el típico síndrome del
sobreviviente que es algo así como no
voy a hablar de mi sufrimiento por las
víctimas porque sobrevivió y los demás
no eso es lo que es culpa de alguna
manera tenía la sensación de que no
entendía porque yo había sobrevivido y
los otros no y por qué seguía vivo
cuando a pocos centímetros de mí a mi
derecha o a mi izquierda sabía que había
personas que habían perdido la vida
Cuando vidiarme con todo lo que sufría
desde hace varios años enseguida
reconocí lo que se conoce como el
síndrome del sobreviviente
esa culpa que se arraiga en la memoria
de quienes sobrevivieron a un
acontecimiento catastrófico y vieron
personas moridas alrededor
muchas víctimas desarrollaron estas
heridas psicológicas sin recibir ningún
tipo de atención ayuda o apoyo
sin embargo debido al ocurrido en el
estadio de furiani este tipo de
traumadores reconocido
desde furiani y ese fue el momento de
tunante hay células médicas y
psicológicas de emergencias
sistemáticamente en este tipo de
situaciones y al mismo tiempo que se
Presta atención médica o quirúrgica se
Presta atención psicológica a todas las
personas implicadas incluso a las que
estaban lejos así en 1995 Durante los
atentados del metro de París las
unidades de emergencia prestaron
atención inmediata a Los afectados
psicológicamente desde entonces esta
atención se ha convertido en algo
sistemático
Ismael triki antiguo defensa del
Sporting club de bastià ahora es
entrenador de los equipos de las
categorías inferiores entre los niños
algunos tienen un padre o un familiar
que estaba en el partido ese día durante
el caos todos trataron de ayudar lo
mejor que podían como Ismael que al ver
un joven con una pierna gravemente
herida lo cubrió con su cortavientos El
joven se llama deny yo seguía buscando a
la persona en la había dado el
cortavientos y un día por casualidad en
una fiesta de cumpleaños él estaba
contando su historia sobre la tragedia
de furiani porque sabía que yo era
futbolista yo estaba escuchando su
historia le dije yo le di mi
cortavientos a un niño que tenía una
pierna rota Tenía algo no se quería ir y
él me dijo que sí yo dije entonces eres
tú y él me dijo sí soy yo
tras la tragedia se creó un colectivo su
objetivo es ayudar a las víctimas a
obtener justicia reparación y
reconocimiento de su estatus Josefa
gidicelli es la presidenta del colectivo
de víctimas ella que perdió a su padre
el 5 de mayo de 1992 Nunca ha dejado de
hacer que las víctimas sean recordadas
hoy en día sigue denunciando lo que
provocó la catástrofe
isaberrante en pocos días lograron
arrasar con la vieja Tribuna y duplicar
o triplicar el número de asientos para
generar dinero
porque hay que decir las cosas como son
hay que recordar que la tragedia de
furiani se debe a la codicia
una Tribuna construida a toda prisa
desafiando las normas elementales de
seguridad parece que para el bastial las
ganancias eran prioridad por encima de
la seguridad de los espectadores
ha sido periodista en la radio rcfm
durante más de 30 años como observador
privilegiado de la vida deportiva local
y nacional ha constatado a lo largo de
su extensa carrera cambios esenciales en
la forma de recibir a los espectadores
en los eventos públicos
Afortunadamente no hemos encontrado
ninguna Tribuna como esa desde entonces
[Música]
desde lo sucedido en furiani se botó una
ley que prohíbe la construcción de
tribunas de ese tipo a gran escala
Porque habíamos llegado al tope 10.000
personas en un andamio de metal y tablas
[Música]
en el trigésimo aniversario de la
catástrofe Josefa quinicelli y los
miembros del colectivo organizaron una
semana de conmemoración para todos
sobrevivientes y testigos es una
oportunidad para subrayar que la
tragedia ha sido un poco olvidada por el
continente así lo confirma didierray
historiador deportivo
la dimensión nacional que debió haber
tenido es para que cosas de esta
magnitud no vuelvan a ocurrir para que
uno no vaya a un partido y se muera allá
para que no perdamos la vida ya o que
uno queda discapacitado algunos han
cargado con el peso de furiani durante
30 años
para conmemorar aquella fatídica
semifinal de 1992 un partido
conmemorativo reunió a antiguos
jugadores de los equipos de Marsella y
bastian
corriendo más lento y con algunos kilos
de más vinieron de toda Europa fue un
partido simbólico por supuesto pero muy
importante para el imaginario colectivo
corso
ellos vivieron y de cerca
jugadores de fútbol pasaron a ser
paramédicos se pusieron manos a la obra
nosotros los jugadores de fútbol
derribamos la valla para que la gente
pudiera salir tuvimos que decirle a la
gente que saltara no sabíamos que iba a
pasar Tal vez ellos también se iban a
caer así que tuvimos el reflejo de abrir
la valla y dejar salir a la gente dentro
del estadio
Aunque desde furiani ya no existen las
tribunas mortales
Aunque ahora las víctimas son atendidas
sistemáticamente queda un punto esencial
para los corsos
que se respete su luto en este fatídico
día
si Domo
si yo sufrí una Amnesia traumática tengo
la impresión de que las autoridades
futbolísticas francesas aunque no están
traumatizadas también han sufrido una
verdadera Amnesia
que son completamente
esta tragedia pues siguieron jugando
fútbol el 5 de mayo de ayer incluso
cuando había partidos el 5 de Mayo no se
hacía referencia a esa fecha ni se
guardaba Un minuto de silencio ni se
rendía un homenaje etcétera
ante esta indiferencia hacia los 19
muertos y los 2.357 heridos el colectivo
trató de obtener la suspensión
definitiva de los partidos profesionales
ese día
Tratamos de contactar a las autoridades
futbolísticas pero no obtuvimos
respuesta nos topamos con un muro por
parte de la liga de fútbol profesional y
su presidente Federico Es cierto que no
entendió nuestra petición no le importó
Por qué no le estábamos pidiendo la luna
el 5 de Mayo es un día del año es fácil
aplastar un partido Por mal tiempo u
otras razones
La indiferencia de las autoridades
futbolísticas ante el desastre deportivo
que más muertes ha provocado en Francia
llevó al colectivo a buscar otros medios
de acción la lucha se convirtió entonces
en una lucha política Michael castellani
encargado de un proyecto de ley que
prohíbe todos los partidos profesionales
el 5 de mayo se encontró con obstáculos
que no podía haberse imaginado
las autoridades futbolísticas francesas
ven con muy malos ojos que los políticos
se inmiscuyan en sus asuntos
Así que hubo una resistencia muy fuerte
por parte de las autoridades
futbolísticas
tuvimos que superar eso fue difícil
porque hubo presiones primero sobre mí y
después sobre un cierto número de
diputados para que no votaran a favor de
este proyecto de ley
el texto fue aprobado finalmente por la
asamblea nacional casi por unanimidad en
octubre de 2021
[Aplausos]
adiós
el trabajo de memoria finalmente tuvo
éxito pero fueron necesarios 30 años de
lucha 30 años de combates para que el 5
de mayo se convirtiera en un día de
conmemoración
[Música]
[Aplausos]
Gracias por acompañarnos en esta edición
de boleto de vuelta que en esta
oportunidad nos llevó a Francia
visitando tres décadas después
supervivientes y familiares de las
víctimas de uno de los capítulos más
oscuros del fútbol francés y mundial
recuerde que puede Ingresar a nuestra
página web France 24.com para ver esta
emisión y las anteriores Hasta pronto